right-wingers have gotten us banned from
being able to post to tick tock
I don't even know where to start but
this is quite frankly completely
demoralizing we have been posting on the
platform Tick Tock for a while now we
have built up more than 200 000
followers on Tick Tock the fastest
growth of any platform on which we have
ever published content has been Tick
Tock the growth has been incredible it
has become a huge part of our content
distribution
tick tocks content moderation system is
a disaster it's heavily automated
and it appears as though when human
reviewers are involved they either don't
understand the content or are hypocrites
I don't know
and because we have had
dozens of videos flagged by right
Wingers wrongly flagged as violating all
sorts of different disinformation
policies although most of those we have
appealed successfully
enough of them we have not that now we
are banned from posting to tick tock for
some period of time take a look at this
when we enter Tick Tock we now see your
account is in view only mode that means
can't post can't comment due to multiple
violations of our community guidelines
your account is restricted to view only
mode the next violation could result in
being permanently banned
this is a major hit to what we are doing
and the messages we are trying to get
out look at some of these examples of
our violations Senator Mike Braun says
he would be okay leaving the legality of
interracial marriage to states that was
from March we posted that and said how
horrible it was that Mike Braun said
that Mike Braun really said that we got
a violation
because the content was found to be uh
intended to deceive or mislead
that's insane we were debunking what
Mike Braun genuinely said next example I
interviewed Bobby pyton a republican for
U.S Senate he made false claims about
the 2020 election I debunked those
claims
and we got a violation for that
Trump is confused by election fraud
documentary this was an interview that
Luke Beasley did with someone who told
lies about the 2020 election Luke
Beasley confronted those lies lies we
called out those lies
and it was found to violate Community
guidelines and we also have one which is
under appeal
wherein Donald Trump called Joe Biden
the Enemy of the State that's literally
what Trump said we talked about how
corrosive and destructive that is we
received
a community guideline strike these are
right Wingers Mass reporting us so what
can we do I don't know
if you work at Tick Tock if you know
anyone who works at Tick Tock please get
us in touch email info davidpackman.com
this is a really important platform on
which we are reaching young people who
vote
this is a huge part of our Outreach and
the Maga people by mass reporting us
have gotten it taken away and part
listen they do this on every platform
they do this on YouTube YouTube has
figured out
how not to allow these people it's just
simply because they don't like my
opinion to shut down my channel Tick
Tock has not figured it out
if you know anyone at Tick Tock please
get in touch put us in touch we need
help
in addition
get yourself some membership on our
website we all all of these platforms
take up time and resources and every
time that something like this happens we
then have to request additional help and
additional resources and additional time
the best thing we can do in order to not
rely on any individual platform is to
continue growing the direct support from
our viewers so I would love it if you
signed up at joinpakman.com coupon code
big voting 22 gets you a discount